The key to handling conflict is not what
you say, it is what you observe. In
today's episode, I'm going to teach you
exactly what I teach every single one of
my legal clients. So, if you've ever
wondered, what's it like to be a legal
client of Jefferson? Well, today is your
chance to do that. Today's the lucky
day. We're going to dive into how do you
handle high stress conflict situations
and operate at a different level that
you did not know was possible. All
right, now let's keep going. When we
talk about difficult, high stress
conflict, I'm I'm talking about not just
a little bitty everyday arguments. I'm
talking about something that's on your
plate that's coming up right now. And
you go, Jefferson, I don't know how to
handle this. I I don't know what to do.
I'm afraid I'm going to shut down. I'm
afraid I'm going to get nervous. I'm
going to tell you exactly what I tell
every single one of my clients. You
ready? Number one, it is not what you
say. It is not anything to do with your
mouth. It has everything to do with your
nervous system. And the key here is
instead of absorbing,
you're observing. I'm going to say it
again. Instead of absorbing,
you're observing. If you want to handle
conflict at a different level of
consciousness that you did not know you
could handle it, it is going to be the
key of not absorbing what they say, but
observing what they say. All right, say
it with me. Say it with me wherever you
are. It's not absorbing, it's observing.
All right. What does that mean? I want
you to think, this is just coming to me
right now. I want you to think you're in
the grocery store and you have your your
cart with you and you're going through
and you or maybe maybe you're somebody
who likes a bag. You know, you you you
have a I'm I'm all for environmentally
friendly stuff, too, though it's hard
here in Texas. and you have your cart
and you just start putting things on the
shelf or grabbing things off the shelf
and putting it in your basket that you
you don't even want, right? You don't
even want the things just start to come
in. You're like, "Yeah, you know what?
I'm going to take their belittling
opinion of me. I'm going to put it in my
cart. You know, I'm going to take their
side eye, put it in my cart. I'm going
to take that that disrespectful tone and
put that in my cart." And you just keep
going all the way through aisle by
aisle. And then you go to check out,
which is actually a very good word for
this. Yeah. You you you mentally check
out and you know what checks in? Your
nervous system, your emotions, and they
just flood you in that moment. And and
in that point in time, you have
absorbed. You have taken on so many
things that there's nothing left for
you. You're not observing. You're not
seeing what's happening. You're just in
it. You're just in it. And you are
helpless to it. It is no longer you who
controls the emotions. The emotions are
now controlling you. And there's no
telling what you're going to say.
There's no there's no nobody can guess
what's going to come out of your mouth
or what's going to happen because you're
not there. You are checked out. So, when
I tell my clients, hey, when you're in
the chair and somebody is the other
attorney is asking you questions,
there's going to be a time where all of
a sudden you're tempted to go in it to
to to go down the spiral and look inside
and look at yourself and feel emotions
and get heated because you're going to
start taking things personally. You're
going to start absorbing what they're
saying. No, no, no, no. If you want to
handle this the right way, the proper
way in conflict, you have to start
observing. What does that mean? That
means you're going to approach the
conversation at a different level of
consciousness that you have before. That
means instead of going, "How how could
he say that to me? Oh my gosh, I'm" and
you start holding your breath and you
start getting flustered and you get
nervous or maybe you tear up. It's
because you're not seeing it as, "Huh, I
wonder why he's asking me this. I wonder
why she's saying that. I wonder where
they're going with this." Look for the
intent behind the words.
the intent behind the words when you are
observing what's happening in some sense
being an attached observer. I've said
this before where you it's like you are
sitting in a movie theater with your
popcorn and you're watching the
conversation take place and that puts
you in a different perspective of
looking at the person who's talking to
you and thinking, I wonder why that
character is saying this. I wonder what
the plot is. I wonder what the narrative
is. I I wonder what scene is coming up
next. And you see how when you look at
it that way, you have full control.
You're now the director, the producer,
the screenwriter of exactly what happens
next. And then it's just action. And
you're able to be in the state of mind
of, hey, I'm observing the conversation.
And from there, that gives you a chance
to let your body regulate because you're
not in it. You are seeing it. You're
seeing the conversation. Number two,
what I teach every one of my clients is
something that's at the forefront of my
book, The Next Conversation, Argue Less,
Talk More. And rule number one when I
say say it with control and that is let
your breath
be the first word that you say.
I've been talking a little fast here in
this podcast which is unlike me. I think
I'll tell you why I drink too much
coffee this morning. Too much coffee.
Admittedly, usually I talk pretty slow.
All right. Can you hear how just the way
I'm talking now and how I'm slowing down
just a little bit might in a micro
percentage also slow you down a little
bit. Maybe you know the neural activity
in your brain is starting to slow down
just a little bit. Maybe you feel a
little bit more relaxed at me speaking a
little more slowly. When I put
a breath before my words,
it is making sure that I am regulating
myself. And even more importantly, I am
showing you
I am showing you that I am regulated,
that I am in control. And what I'm about
to say, I've chosen.
I've chosen those words
makes a very big difference. So when I
teach my clients, hey, don't get wrapped
up. Don't try and step on somebody's
question. Don't try to interrupt them.
Let them get it out and then you observe
the question. Observe the the
interaction. Take a breath
and then choose what you want to say.
You are in complete control of the pace
of any conversation. Nobody can make you
say anything you don't want to say and
nobody can make you say it at a time you
don't want to say it. That choice is
yours. That choice is yours. And I
cannot tell you how many clients I have
seen come to find accept and grow in
their own power and their own sense of
value and worth of wow I I get to choose
if I say anything. And you know what? If
I want to wait 30 seconds before I say
something, I can do that.
It's it is a freeing feeling to know,
you know, I'm going to think about this.
Let me chew on this question for a
second.
Just that alone, the ability to say that
says, "Oh, no, no. I'm I'm operating at
a different level you don't know about.
No, I'm I'm not who you thought I was. I
know exactly what I'm doing. I'm going
to choose my words and I'm going to show
you that what I'm about to say is
something that I absolutely mean and I'm
saying with intention, right? Can you
feel the difference? Say, what kind of
breath are we talking about? I've run
through this breath before. It's always
good to do it because it's something
that is good for me, too. Is a
conversational breath. And what it does,
it's based on a physiological sigh,
which is a double Oh, that kind of
sounded weird. Double inhalation.
double inhalation. So, you're breathing,
you're inhaling twice. All right? So,
ready with me? We're going to breathe
through your nose. Wherever you are,
just do it. Don't worry about it. People
might look at you. Don't worry. Ready?
We're going to breathe in through your
nose about two to three seconds.
One more at the top [snorts]
and then let out through your nose.
My guess is you're starting to come down
a little bit. Maybe your shoulders
relaxed a little bit. is the feeling
that mimics a sigh. When you use that
kind of breath, and I promise you, you
continue to do it while I'm talking
right now, you'll see that you get
really good at it. You can do it any
time. The most crucial part for me is
when I teach my clients to do it is
before they answer the question. Just
take two seconds or one second. What we
like to say here in the South is just
say one Mississippi. In other words, in
in your head, you're going to go
Mississippi.
Like, well, you can use your own name if
you have a long name. You know, just
whatever it is, it's it's to get you in
the mindset of taking a beat, a moment.
Take that breath and choose what you
want to say. It is always going to be
better. And number three, the third
thing that I teach every single one of
my clients is to use less words. Say
less. Now, in the legal context, if my
witness starts to give a very long
answer, you know what happens? Every Why
do I say it like that? Happens.
What happens is I guarantee them that
the opposing attorney is now going to
slice up
that long answer they just gave and turn
that into five more questions, 10 more
questions. The shorter the answer, the
stronger, more clear it is. every single
time. If I give you an answer that is
short and concise, you can do nothing
with it. You can do nothing with it.
Hear the difference. So, I might have a
client who I've trained and we we
practice a lot. [snorts] And when she
might take a breath and answer a
question and go,
"No."
And that's it. That's the only answer.
What What can the other attorney do?
Nothing. They can't do anything with it.
They can only go to their next question.
But I've also had it despite my training
and teaching where somebody goes,
you know, I'm not sure, you know, that
it was just such a hectic day and you
know, I forgot to go pick up the eggs
and my and my dog was sick and you know,
he just it just, you know, peanut butter
messes up his system and I just find
that you're going and I'm going, "Oh my
gosh, what is happening?" So that
happens. That happens because people are
are human, right? So we have to take a
break and I go, "What? What are we
doing? Come on, get back in it with me.
So, you see the difference in if
somebody's giving a very long answer,
some practical things happen. One is I'm
g the witness is giving more information
than is needed, right? Unnecessary
information, which means the other
person, let's put this in everyday
application. Everyday people are going
to get confused as to what the answer
is. They're going to fill in their own
assumptions of why you're not answering
it directly. they're going to hear that
there's just more words which just
automatically leads to the possibility
of more confusion and more
miscommunication. We don't want that. We
want short concise. So I like to say it
when I when I teach is that if I ask you
do you have the time? Do you know what
time it is?
That means I'm going to ask you to stop
and ask that question in your mind. Do I
know what time it is? What am I asking?
Do you know what time it is? And if you
give me the time, oh, it's um 8:03.
That's the wrong answer. That's the
wrong answer. If I say, "Do you know the
time?" The answer is yes, I do. It's
that detailed. It is that detailed
because in my world, it has to be that
detailed. You have to be in in everyday
conversation. those high stake, high
emotions, just when everything is on the
the table, everything's on the line,
every little word of clarity matters a
great deal. And I have to make sure that
you're prepared. So when you condense
your words into something that is very
short, very concise, the longer of an
answer you give, the more opportunity
there is for miscommunication, more
opportunity there is for somebody to
take your answer and twist it. Here's an
example. Have you ever been in a text
argument with somebody? I have. I know
you have. And it they just sent you
something and you're like, "Oh, really?"
and you just start texting on your
phone, just going after it, and you
write a paragraph. I'm talking you just
you hit them so good and it's perfect
and you're it's it's this is exactly how
I feel and you send it and they send a
text that doesn't even address anything
that you said at all. Or maybe they
addressed one part that they could
defend and like, but they ignored all
the rest. is that same principle. You're
giving someone way too much to take and
to twist. So, if you want to handle high
conflict, like I teach every one of my
clients, you have to keep your answers
as short as possible. Answer their
question and only their question. All
right. Okay. Hey, look, you you're
ready. You're ready. I know we we maybe
we're going to need to talk about this.
Let's go grab some coffee. Make sure you
get some snacks. Feel good. We're about
to go into this deposition room together
and you're going to do awesome. I
promise. What do we talk about today
when it comes to high stakes
conversation? Number one, observe. Don't
[snorts]
absorb.
Observe. Don't absorb. Number two, use
your breath
[sighs and gasps] as the first word that
you say. Slow it down and choose your
words. Be intentional with them. Make
sure that you are operating on your time
frame, not somebody else's. And number
three, say less. Shorten your answers.
When you give way too much, you allow
the opportunity for somebody to grab
onto it pieces and say things you didn't
mean. You're giving them more to twist.
You're giving them more to twist. It's
like uh giving somebody a long piece of
rope. They they're able to put a bunch
of knots in it. But if you just give
them a little bit of rope, it maybe it's
not even enough to do a a to tie their
shoe with, right? It's a big difference.
You want to make sure that you're very
short and concise. Man, my u examples
today are all over the place. We talked
about the grocery store. We talked about
shoelaces. Man, what a what a day. What
an episode. I've read that you have a
mantra. You like to say, "Observe, don't
absorb."
Many of our listeners um have a tendency
when especially when constructive
feedback is sent their way to to really
feel it to to to take it on and perhaps
get defensive. What advice and guidance
do you have to help us really be present
and observe without absorbing something
and perhaps reacting too soon or too
negatively?
What I mean is you get to watch a
conversation happen
without absorbing all of it and deciding
that well what they say is just who I
am. So if you were to have the mindset
of there is something for me here if I'm
willing to listen then things tend to go
better. I know that when you get
feedback from somebody you know they
they say don't take criticism from
somebody you wouldn't take advice from.
Um it's it's um it's a balance between
hearing what they say and knowing are
they meaning it for your good or
ultimately, you know, for your peril.
Are they wanting to actually try and
build you up? Is it something that you
just feel sensitive about? Did they hit
something on a nerve or are you actually
interested in trying to build on with
it? So, it's it's all contextual. I
really like everything you said, but the
thing that really stood out to me was
there's something to learn here and when
you look for the learning uh especially
if it's coming from a source you respect
uh it can be very helpful and and that
can help uh take away perhaps some of
the initial defensiveness that one feels
and approaching it from a place of
gratitude and expressing your your
gratitude and saying thanks can really
help with some of that. I want to move
to uh a different topic. Uh often our
meetings and conversations can go off
the rails. They don't go the way we
expected. You have a framework you call
one frame, one issue.
How can we set appropriate
conversational frames at the beginning
or even before we begin the the
conversation so that we can manage this
and keep it on track in a way that we
want so we don't have scope creep or
anxiety that comes from that? I cannot
stand meetings where you you get in,
they go, "Okay, everybody, we have a lot
to cover today.
You never get out of it feeling like you
covered really anything, you know,
because it was just too you're too
spread thin." Rather than going deep on
a few issues. It's applying that same
kind of idea. When you talk about
everything, you talk about nothing at
the same time. So, what does a frame do?
Like a picture, it enhances what's in
it. If I can put a frame around the
conversation, it does two things. One,
it enhances the conversation. It
highlights it. It makes it very clear.
Second, what it does is it gets rid of
all the anxiety of the stuff that you
might think we're going to be talking
about. So, if I text you and I say, "We
need to talk."
And nobody gets that text and goes, "Oh,
hi five. Yes, I can't wait." It's always
terrible that that feeling. Why? because
you have that all that anxiety about
what are we going to talk about? Well,
you can remove that anxiety by using a
frame and I really have it in three
three steps is one and I tell somebody
what I want to talk about. Give them the
gift of telling them what you want to
talk about. Don't make them have to ask.
Tell them what you want to talk about.
The topic, the subject, whatever it is.
Number two, tell them how you want the
conversation to end. What's what's the
checkered flag? Where are you going?
What do you want to what I like to use
is what I want to take away from. What
do I want to walk away from the
conversation? And then three, I get
their buy in into it. That's as simple
as sound good. Does that work? Can we do
that? Because once you get that little
nod of, yeah, I'll talk to you about
that. It's it's like an implicit
contract. They they they now are bought
into, well, I committed to talking to
this about you. Now they know I don't
have to talk about anything else.
there's no other collateral issues, but
yet you have a straight path A to B. I
know exactly what we're going to talk
about. I know when it's when we've
checked the box and three, I've I'm
built into it. So, it's a way of
removing the difficult from difficult
conversations and now it's just talking.
>> How does somebody acquire
the skills to like slow down and not
feel as if
it'll work?
>> Yeah.
>> You know what I mean? Let me let me tell
you something that will help or help
that has helped me
>> and let me tell you said I work on this
all the time. All right, I'm I am no
different than anybody else and I'm
probably worse. All right, so it's if I
can
>> let's say it's you, anybody
listening, it's think of you and your
partner and you're in a disagreement.
All right. Typically, there's something
that is said that I'm going to grab on
to because I disagree with it strongly.
And it might be something small like you
always, you never, and I'm like, I I I
never Are you kidding? Don't you
remember? And I just take off.
All right. Now, if I have the mental
discipline to just take it as a cloud
passing of like, okay, noted. That's one
thing I don't like, but I'm going to
keep listening.
>> Nope. I don't like that either. I want
keep listening rather than storing them
up as ammunition and sidelining it. If I
can just pause and put away my
disagreement for a second, my
frustration for a second
and take that moment to acknowledge
first, reach understanding first to say,
"Yeah, that that I can see why you're
frustrated. That sounds really
frustrating." that is not at all what I
meant to do and watch them calm down.
Then
then I can say and then they'll be open
to me saying can I share something with
you that that I'm struggling with. All
right. You you said that I never
and usually by the time I even get to
that you you said that I never they're
going what I've had many times is
they'll say yeah I I know it's not
never. I was just frustrated with like
if you can just pause. I'm telling you
said if you just are able to take the
frustration and set it aside even for a
little bit and just acknowledge first
it opens up everything to be able to
then you can one sift out is that thing
that I was disagreeing with really that
important or is that just me trying to
protect myself and be defensive.
>> It's it's really the the modes of
protection. I'm going to be dismissive.
I'm gonna say that thing, that insulting
thing, I'm gonna make it hurt just to
protect my own self because I don't like
being called out. I don't like being
told that I'm wrong. I don't like being
told I could have handled that
differently.
>> Um, as soon as you
are able to just set it aside and
understand first, reach validation
first. Yeah, that sounds really
frustrating. Of course, you would be
upset by that. Yeah, if if that's what
you you took away from that. Yeah, I
could definitely see why you're
frustrated. Boom. It slows everything
down. Yeah. And then you can address,
hey, you said something that
um hurt me and I want to talk about it.
You said this.
>> Now you're able what's you're going to
find is repair there rather than trying
to take off on something that within
five minutes you're a million miles away
and you don't even know how you got
there anymore. That I'm telling you
that's
>> that's been the key for me. I I I can't
imagine there being a better way to to
slow conversations down. And I know
we're really harping on not we're really
focusing on deep relationship work
>> right now,
>> which I appreciate. I like this
conversation.
>> Yeah. I think deep relationship work is
what matters. Like it was interesting
when we were talking you were like,
"Well, I'm talking about the people that
we really care about." And like see that
was the key. Like that's what we're
talking about. The people that we care
about cuz like I mean I'm telling you
Jeff Je like I can be like, "Bro, who's
that?" Like I ain't got nothing to say
to you. I I'll pass you up quick.
>> Exactly.
>> But the people that I care about those
that's I'm I'm constantly working on how
I can communicate better. And there's
nothing better than pausing. And when
you And it's funny cuz when you first
start pausing, it's really uncomfortable
for everyone. For everyone that's
uncomfortable, especially when we're
just conditioned to like go have an
answer right away that isn't even
>> thought through. Well, you know what I
mean?
>> Um like a deep relationships is what we
all crave. And that's why I wanted to
talk to you about that because
we don't really know how to navigate
them well because we're working with
what we with the information that we
have which is typically from our parents
how we were raised and some people may
have had good communication skills but
what's funny is when you get with
somebody in relationship kids wife
friends you come from two completely
different worlds and when you come
together there's going to be some some
tustling there's going to be some um
disagreements only because again our
communication isn't there like we don't
know how to communicate to each other in
the air quotes right way. You know what
I'm saying?
>> Yeah, I do. I do.
>> So, it's like constantly I love what you
said um another thing you said about
like the clouds passing by. I'm kind of
like a visual guy and I'm like think
about it like oh yeah like oh she said
that like all right well all right well
I'm I'm it's like the clouds passing by
also see like the layers coming back
from like an onion and like I see myself
just pausing. And it's like those are
the three things that I see. And I think
if I can do that for myself personally,
realizing I have to it's my job to water
the the roots. Don't pay attention to
like the the leaves and just focus on
like what my job is as a for this person
that I love. I mean that's like the
bigger person, right? Like that's what
being the bigger person is,
>> right?
>> It is. It's be it's being the the
safety. It's that's what it is. Um
Like we mentioned,
we want we all deeply want somebody to
be with us in our messy because we have
a deeply rooted fear
that
I am too much or I am not enough and
this person's going to leave me.
that if I tell the truth
that they're not going to love me
anymore. And in many ways that turns
into lies. Protect me.
>> And
that is a very dangerous road. Uh that
is a that is a road of
corrosiveness that will hurt uh
everybody you love. So what what can you
do? I think what you just outlined is a
great way to to put this in a frame so
to speak. One, whenever you get to that
situation of whoever you are with that
you have a a deep feelings for
one, what are the roots? That's asking
the question, what's coming up for you?
Asking yourself the question, what are
they feeling right now? What am I
feeling right now? when I can voice it.
That would be number two, voicing how
you're feeling. If I slow down and I
say, I can tell that I'm I'm getting
frustrated. I can tell that I'm getting
defensive. I can tell that
I I need some time. That is such a
higher level IQ move than me reacting to
that. There's such a there's a
difference between me saying I can tell
I'm getting defensive
versus me acting defensive and saying
are are you kidding me? Oh yeah, okay.
Me? What about you? What about that time
that you and it's done?
>> You're never going to reach them now.
Now congratulations. You've now won
yourself three more arguments. You
you've now added on three more hours of
hard feelings between the two of you.
Like that's that's how quick it is to to
go off the the tangent. So if you were
to number two, just vocalize it of how
you're feeling and asking how they're
feeling.
That's always going to help get to the
the roots. And number three, I'm going
to choose to no matter the situation,
you find yourself to be the the anchor
of the conversation to show that you can
slow it down, that you're not going
anywhere. You're not trying to push the
conversation. You're not even trying to
push them. You're just here to listen,
absorb, validate.
And that's how you grow deeper. That uh
because now I now the other person feels
like you can be trusted. Now they feel
like your your bond is closer with them.
Like think of it with with our kids.
Yeah. How old are your kids?
>> Eight, six, and three.
>> Okay, there you go. So, we're we're very
similar. All right.
When I Is isn't it true that when you
look at your one of your kids so often
you see yourself?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, my son, he's seven.
He will say things and react in ways and
I go, "Oh my gosh, that is so me.
>> Oh my goodness, that is me." And it is
such a teaching tool for me because
we're all just big kids. I mean, I look
in the mirror and I go, "I can't believe
I look this old." Like I My dad would
always tell me I I he always say, "I
look in the mirror and and ask who's
this old man?"
>> You know, because on the inside, we're
we're just the same. We we feel in
mentally like we're in our 20s, like
we're not old enough to be adults yet.
And now all of a sudden we have kids and
responsibilities, but emotionally we a
lot of us are still the same way. We
were never we were never validated at
the age of eight. We were never
validated at the age of 18. Why in the
world would we feel validated at the age
of 48?
>> It's all the same. It's all the same.
And so when I can see my child and take
that as a reflection of God, I feel the
same way when he's reacting like this.
Yeah. I I feel that frustration too. My
daughter, you know, I we always know
when she's upset cuz she will
>> just out of nowhere will hear a like a
big she's just, you know, she can't get
her hair the way that she wants. She's
frustrated that
>> she can't get her shoe on the right way.
like she and so am I. My wife will go,
"Yeah, that's me." Like it's
>> it's just so funny to they're just
little uses around
>> and to say this is my chance to to see
that that I'm still I'm still there. So
if my son needs that or my daughter
needs that kind of validation, why would
my spouse not? We're we're we're we're
all parents for the first time. I mean,
it's it's all it's all the same. And so
I I really love
I really I truly do love seeing
how much healing I can have in my own
life by observing
the lived experiences of my children
when it comes to to communication, how I
can validate their emotions. Yeah. I I
didn't grow up. Maybe you feel the same
way. Mhm.
>> Wasn't really okay to cry. Um, really
wasn't. And my son, I let him just be a
waterworks. I mean, I I love I love all
the tears that he has. He feels his
emotions really big.
>> And I think for a lot of men, that was
taught early that was not okay.
>> And there's a consequence to that, too.
So, it's it's it's good to see. I think
it's healthy. So if somebody is of that
type when they're just asked a question
and they just start talking right away,
what can they do to take time and space
for themselves to pause and just think
and sort through their ideas?
>> What they need to do is make their
breath the first word that they say. So
rather than going straight into the
conversation, rather than just start
with the the word vomit, the let me
spill out my ideas, if you just take a
breath
right before you respond,
what it's doing is not only regulating
your body, you know, making sure you're
more aware and in control of your
emotions. It is signaling to the other
person that what I'm about to say has
been thought about, has been
acknowledged. There's a difference of
you asking me a question. Hey Jefferson,
how was your day? And I went, it was
good. It was good, Chris. It was fine.
It was fine. It was a good day. Doesn't
really sound like I really thought about
it, but if you asked me, hey Jefferson,
how was your day? And I went,
you know, Chris, it was good. It was a
good day. Ups and downs, but it was
good. Which one of those sounds like I
actually acknowledged what you said,
really thought about it, and and in
exchange you actually want to hear what
I'm about to say more? Like same thing
with in an interview. That's probably
one of the top things I talk about with
friends that are going into an interview
and they're like, "Hey, what should I
do?" It's like the slower you answer the
question, the better the interview will
be. They ask you a question and you just
immediately try to it has to be as fast
as possible. That's the opposite. What
you are need needing to exude in that
moment is I can take stressful moments
including the interview that I'm in
and be able to regulate myself and show
you that I'm not somebody who runs in
conversation. I walk in it. And whenever
you slow yourself down, they're going to
find that what you're saying is they're
going to even feel that what you're
saying is more thought out and more
intentional than if it's just off the
cuff.
to the best of your ability to recall
when do you first remember this being a
conscious thought or effort from your
part?
I started teaching clients this very
early on in my really as a first year
associate. Uh I was at a law firm that
was the type that you know I wasn't
behind a lot of partners. It was like
these are your clients. You either sink
or swim get after it. So you really go
to your first trial, your first year by
yourself. And I can remember training
some of the first people
on they get so nervous before their
deposition. There's cameras, there's
other people, and I'm teaching them,
okay, instead of just going right into
it, they ask you a question. Instead of
just having an immediate response, take
a minute. And some I would say, I want
you to just count one Mississippi.
That's it. Just one. And I mean, I did
all kinds of things to try and get them
to remember it. And so then what I would
do is I would put on the hat of being
the opposing attorney. And I'd say,
"Okay, Chris, you know, you understand
that you're here today. Is that ain't
that true?" And I would start to kind of
pressure them and get them all kind of
worked up. And I'd say, "Okay, this is
the moment. This is where count just in
your head, one Mississippi.
Okay, now answer." Instead of feeling
like you're in their time frame, in
their time space, you're controlling it.
You're saying, "Nope, I'm the one that's
driving in my lane. You can't do
anything about it." So, it's really it's
like teaching defensive driving verbally
and how to do that. Now, on the flip end
of that is I I'm a fifth generation
trial attorney. All the men in my
attorney family are attorneys, women,
too. And my dad is this way. I could
come to my dad with an issue and I'd
say, "Oh, that we got this. We have this
problem." And he'd go,
"Yep, that's a problem." You know what I
mean? Like that. who's just always
[laughter] very very very keel. And so I
would be I would be like, "Oh my gosh,
Dad, they're going to be they're but
they're going to be really upset." And
he would take a beat and say, "Yep, I
guess they'll be upset." That was just
his type of demeanor.
>> And so, of course, it's just genetics
mirroring that my entire life. Um, yeah,
he was he would always exude the the run
or the walk don't run kind of mentality.
>> I can feel my energy change just by the
way that you were changing your tone and
the pace in which you were talking.
>> This is just goes to to the point of
like how much the tone and the way that
you deliver. the words matter sometimes
even more than the words because when
you were putting on that like um that
mock trial thing with the opposing
council saying so what were you I just
felt like whoa
>> like I'm going to say something probably
not that smart probably something that's
going to incriminate myself right then
>> right right even if you don't mean to
>> yeah I I just felt it right away because
your baseline is so calm reassuring and
and just gentle and inviting that the
minute that you switched that up I could
feel it immediately
I'm sure I'm not the only one. If you're
listening to this, just let us know that
I'm not the only person who felt that.
>> Right. Right. Right. Well, the thing is
anybody can do it, Chris. It's I mean,
it's more natural to me because this is
how I was raised. This is the household
I I I was in. I mean, I was raised on on
the Socratic method. You I'd come with
the problems and my dad would say,
"Well, what do you think they would say
about that?" You know, like he would
always put it in the position of the the
other person and slow me down. But like
if you're listening right now, if you
want to sound more confident, more
respected in your communication and more
even
more serious, more warm, whatever it is,
all you need to do is slow down your
words and lower your volume. It makes a
huge impact. If you are with somebody
who's always loud and very aggressive,
do you want to do more of what they say
or less? So like compare it to to this.
If I were to say, "Look, Chris, I
already told you I'm not I'm I'm not
going to do that versus
Chris already told you I'm not going to
do that." Now, which one of those
is, let's say, somebody who sounds more
grounded, somebody who sounds more
balanced, somebody who sounds more
composed, somebody really you don't want
to mess with. It's actually the person
who sounds less emotional, the person
who sounds less aggressive, who says,
"Oh, no. This is not somebody I want to
mess with." And it's I'm saying the same
thing, but the connotation, the feeling
is very, very different.
>> Okay. You say it, I feel it, I live it.
There's so many people who will hear
this and say like, gosh, I just I can't
figure it out. Now, you must have worked
with some some clients in in the
courtroom where you're like, okay, just
take a breath.
>> We go real slow and then you see them on
the stand and they're like,
>> that's got to happen, right?
>> Oh, yeah. It happens all the time.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And when you're on break, do you
how do you redirect? How do you get them
in that pocket again?
>> Yeah. So, you kind of have to do it
without telling them about it. Like I
have
>> um for example, I had this guy once
who
um you know, he had read some stuff on
Google and he's like, "Oh, no. You know,
I read you need to be, you know, really
short with your answers." I like, "Oh,
that's that's all great." And they on
textbook, they think they got it all
worked out. And despite all of my
preparation with them, they got we had I
had them go right into the deposition.
He started out great. And it it took no
no time at all, Chris. He was starting
to step on the other attorney's
questions. So before the attorney was
actually an finished with their
question, he's already stepping on it
with their answer. So he the question
was something like, you know, now you
went that day. You first drove to your
cousins and you'd be like house. Yep. I
went to their house. So he's stepping on
the the words which you don't want to do
because in terms of the reason why
there's a court reporter is because
everything's written down. So on paper
it doesn't look good. It's what they
would say it's a messy record because
you have these insertions into instead
of a full question a full answer. And he
kept doing it and I was like you know
better. And so in my head I'm like all
right this next question I'm going to
pull him out. So sure enough he answers
the last question stepped on it again.
And I said, "Okay, let's take a we're
just going to take a five-minute break.
Let's just take a little break. You want
to stand up for a second?" He's like,
"Yeah, that's fine." And so we get out
of the room and I just say, "Hey, just
walk with me." And so I'm unrolling a
peppermint while I'm doing it, just
acting super nonchalant. I pop it in my
mouth. I'm just sit right here. We sit
down and I say, "So, um, how old are
your kids again?" And he was like, "Ah,
yeah, you know, seven. Seven and eight."
I was like, "Oh, that's that's great.
That's great. Ages. What? What? What did
y'all uh what' y'all do the last week?
And all of a sudden, he starts to like
calm down. He's like, "Oh, we uh we went
to um a movie." I was like, "What
movie?" He's like, "It's the movie with
the you know the talking animals." I
think it was like um Madagascar, you
know. Uh something like that. Madagascar
2. I was like, "Oh, that's that's
great." I was like, "Was it good?" And
he stops and he slows down and he goes,
"Yeah, I mean it was good. You know, it
was a cute movie." And I said, 'Good.
All right. You see what we're doing
here? He goes, "Yeah." I said, "That's
exactly what you're going to do in
there." I said, "We're going to slow it
down." He goes, "Ah, I'm stepping on it,
aren't I?" I said, "Yep, that's exactly
what you're doing." All right, so let's
let's go back and treat it just like
you're you're talking to me right here.
And sure enough, he went right back.
He's like, he had to hear it. He had to
feel it
>> for me to make him click rather than me
pulling him out and going, "Hey, stop
>> stepping on the question and get let him
get it all out." Okay, that's not going
to do it. But by showing the example,
making them feel like it was or just
right there, keeping it in the pocket. I
was like, let's let's stay right in this
momentum. You feel this? And he was
like, yeah, I feel that. Okay, let's
stay right here. So, I use that phrase
in the pocket a whole lot with him.
>> Okay, this is excellent. Very
interesting how you took it to a very
conversational level where there's
nothing for him to be nervous about.
>> Yeah. and so that he can be a better
performer in the courtroom because there
shouldn't be a difference between this
style of talking versus like when you're
getting grilled by the other attorney.
And I find that in sales,
we can have a normal conversation,
everything's going great, but when
they're on a call with a client, they
get all high pitch, they get really
nervous and anxious, and they start
start talking really fast. They start
doing performative things that they
normally just don't do. So, are we
talking there's this universal concept
about communication? Like how you talk
to a really good friend is how you
should talk everywhere.
In my opinion, yes. Now, I would say
there's a difference in of course
context and environment. I'm not going
to talk to a prospective client the same
way I'm going to talk to my grandmother,
you know, or or or my best friend or my
dad. There's casual situations where
when you and I are in sweatpants and
drinking coffee talking about life, it's
not the same. So, but I would say the
premise holds true that you generally
want everybody to feel very comfortable
around you. Even when you're public
speaking, one of the best compliments
you can get is you seem so comfortable
up there. Yeah. Because when you
understand that I don't have anything to
prove. I'm just telling you what I know.
I can be excited about what I have to
share. And when I get excited about the
message of what I'm giving,
then I can channel that excitement into
how it's going to benefit everybody
else. And that that's a that's a
wonderful thing to be generous with your
words and generous with your message.
Now, if somebody is grilling you in a
deposition type of setting, it is it is
different. It just it's understanding
that you can't make me say anything I
don't want to say and you can't make me
talk any faster than I'm going to
respond. So when I understand that I'm
the one that has control of the steering
wheel at all times, it's a very
confident mindset. It's a gamechanging
type of concept. When you understand
that you you say something to me, I can
choose not to say anything at all. That
is a pretty powerful thing. People feel
like you always have to have a response.
It's not true. So when you're talking in
front of people, even in that sales
context,
if you can't just be you, like we have
such a six sense of knowing when
somebody's being fake. Let me tell you
what, a jury knows immediately, Chris,
if somebody's being fake. And they will
destroy them. They will pour their whole
case out if they feel like they're being
fake. I can't tell you how many times
I've seen a jury totally turn on
somebody's case if they thought that
they were being somebody that they're
not. Like you just meet somebody and go
there's something about them that
doesn't it's just this six sense that we
have. I think it's very
um I don't I I'm not sure if it's just
the DNA of our cavemanlike abilities to
go, "No, something doesn't smell right
about this. I'm not sure what it is, but
something's not." And and it's even
people who try too hard, right? They're
like, "No,
>> they're trying too hard." Like, what
does that even mean? They're they're
being somebody that they're not. Ever
had somebody try to really make you like
them? You're like, it makes you it's
it's a turnoff. Now you definitely don't
like them. Why? because they're trying
too hard to be liked. I don't they're
being somebody that they're not. Uh if a
witness on the stand is faking sympathy,
like trying to gain sympathy, let's say
they kind of act, you can tell they're
being fake emotional about it. They
really don't mean it. Or a jury will
just go, "Nope, we don't trust you. No
credibility. I think you're faking it."
And it's it's King's X uh every time
>> you say we have one of the best great
secret weapons of pausing.
>> Yes.
>> So talk to me about in that moment if
you start to feel the heat, you start to
boil, your blood's boiling cuz someone's
being disrespectful to you, they're
dismissing you. Take me through the
exact steps of how do you pause,
>> how do you collect your mindset and then
come up with a good response.
>> Yeah. So what I talk about is difference
between short pauses and long pauses.
And when somebody says something
disrespectful, what you want is a long
pause. That's somewhere between about
five to eight seconds. It's just a few
seconds of allowing the other person to
hear what they said because let's say
you said something negative to me.
Visually, one, it's going to give me the
feeling of confidence when I see that
word come and just fall to the ground
and understanding I don't have to pick
that up. And it's kind of in that
silence you're looking at it going, "Is
that is that what you wanted to say?
Does that feel good? That that right
there? Are you looking at what I'm
looking at?" And that right there
automatically makes them feel more
powerless and you feel more in control.
And that pause, you are being their
echo. You're being their mirror. So
often if somebody were to say something
ugly and I say nothing at all, often
what they do is they they say it and
hear it back in their mind. And often
people might apologize and go, "I'm
sorry. I shouldn't have said that or
they rephrase it. Or you can ask the
person a was that supposed to these are
questions of what I call intent. So, was
that supposed to hurt me? See how a
question doesn't respond in the way of
sending that zinger back at them. It's a
way of answering without answering. Did
you mean for that to hurt me? Was that
supposed to embarrass me? And you see
how the power is not sending the zinger
to say, "I'm going to make you hurt even
worse." The power is when they throw a
punch, you go, "That didn't hurt." So
that's that's the control that you have
in that moment.
>> And I assume tone matters because even
just the way you said it, it was so
calm. I assume that was supposed to hurt
me.
>> Why did you say that? Versus like, I
assume that was supposed to hurt me. Why
did you say that?
>> Exactly.
>> So take me through how it can be
perceived as you're losing control
versus actually you have control of this
the conversation.
>> Yeah. I mean, you can use just what we
did as an example. So, if I were to say,
"You can't talk to me like that. Are you
kidding me?" versus,
"You cannot talk to me like that." Now,
which one sounds more in control?
>> Oh, definitely the second one.
>> Definitely the second one. And nothing
changes except that you're speaking a
lot slower, which shows I'm in control
of my words, and it also shows I'm in
control of my actions. Because when that
fight or flight kicks in, which you know
all about, you get that emotion. Your
heart starts to beat. You get nervous.
You start to shake. Your voice might
tremble a little bit. You get tears in
your eyes. It's just emotional flooding.
You're telling your body in that moment
when you're not taking a big pause and a
big breath. You're telling your body, I
have a lot to fear right now.
>> I have a lot to be afraid of. So, I have
to be extreme. I have to say that
extreme thing. I have to go all out.
Versus when you slow down and you speak
slowly and even in a lower tone, you're
not only conveying control, you're also
telling your body
this there's nothing to fear here.
>> There's no nothing to threaten me. I'm
safe. And that right there is an
incredibly powerful move uh that you can
flip that script on them to show that
there's nothing here that's that's
threatening me in some way. So that's
what a lot of the pausing does is it
gives a lot of space for them to realize
that what they wanted is not what
they're going to how I see it is when
you say that ugly thing you put it out
on a ledge like you exposed it and
you're hoping you're praying that
somebody will take it. Have you ever
thrown an insult and then they didn't
give it back?
>> Probably.
>> Yeah. And then you go kind of feel like
a jerk later. You realize oh that didn't
hit. And then you feel kind of stupid
because what you sent out, it didn't get
the response. You didn't get the control
and now you feel kind of silly about it.
So that's that's how you do that. So if
I had to break that down, it'd be one,
you want to add about a five to seven
7se second pause, a long pause. Two, you
want to do it long enough to make them
hear their words back. And often you can
just repeat what they said back to them.
So if you said something ugly like you
ever seen, you're an idiot and I waited
five seconds that said I'm an idiot.
Perfect. Three is you're you're allowing
them to show you can ask questions of
intent. Did you mean for that to
embarrass me? Did you say that to hurt
me or offend me? And uh often times
that's all you really need to do to
realize it's not going to be that fun
for them the second time around.
>> Oh my god, that's so good. And then in
talking about the pause in the power of
it, you also talk about in your book the
power of people forcing you to not
pause. And it's their way almost of
asking your question like rushing you to
answer as a way of them controlling you.
>> Yeah. So in legal depositions, attorneys
do it all the time. We want to get you
responding very quickly. And when you
feel pressured, you often do. A lot of
the clients that I have, I have to train
them on let them get all their question
out, give it a pause, then you say
something because otherwise you want to,
hey, did you go the other day? Yes, I
did. They they they like to cut in
because they just want it over. Same
thing in any argument that you have. You
also want that over because you want the
threat to go away. But where you find
the the moment of control and power for
them is when you can add distance
between what they said and your response
in that distance to where you're able to
show them that there's nothing here
that's really going to defeat me in some
way. And so what I like to focus on is
when you are trying to rush your words,
what you're saying them is you're
afraid. Because when you get afraid, you
like to rush your words. And when you
get to slow down, you're in a much
better position almost every single
time. Confident people know they don't
have to say anything. Insecure people
always have something to say, always
have something to add. Insecurities are
loud. Confidence is very quiet. There's
a very big difference in that. people in
your community would want to grasp that
idea of I don't have to say anything
that I don't want to say. Should I not
want to answer that text for 10 minutes?
Maybe I don't want to respond to that
text for the whole day. Then don't. It's
there's no pressure obligation that you
have to send it immediately. You don't
have to send that full paragraph. You
wait. Wait a day. It's going to be a
whole lot better. and you're the one
that's going to feel more controlled and
send the message that you're in more
control of yourself.
>> How hard is that to
allow for space? You talk about in the
book taking a breath like a like a a
pause or a beat before you respond.
>> I feel like whether you're in a
conversation or maybe you're on stage
and you're presenting, a lot of advisers
do that as well. like a a space like
that at first feels like an eternity
even though to the audience like you
barely even took a took a breath. Is
that a muscle you have to exercise and
get comfortable? How do you how would
you recommend to advisers to start to
develop that skill set?
You just got to do it. [clears throat]
That's the hard part. You just got to
choose to do it. it um
once you start doing it and hear the
difference in your language,
it just changes something in you when
you feel the confidence
to wait. I don't have to have the stream
of consciousness where you where people
I know some people they just start
talking and they almost kind of have to
like catch their breath at the end of
talking because they've just gone on and
it's just a nothing but a run of words.
But if I can, whether it's a use of a
small small pause, like just a little
bit to keep you
attentive, right? That just a little bit
on edge or maybe it's something where
you've said something that's pretty
hurtful and rather than me responding, I
just
let it sit five, seven seconds. The
dynamic changes. I don't say any words
but yet I say everything
in the in the silence.
So I I find there's the benefit of
pausing depending on the length is that
to me if you can do it well you can
master conversation.
>> Pausing by itself.
>> Pausing by itself. It's um like you
think of think of people you most
respect.
Most likely they're not really fast
talkers.
Think of people you love to be around.
Think about your grandparents.
Like how do you want people to feel in
conversation? Do you want them to feel
like they're in a cold waiting room at
the doctor or do you want them to feel
like it's your grandfather's living
room? You know, when whenever you are
able to slow down in the conversation,
it's it's relaxing. They'll be they want
to tell you more because they feel like
this is a safe space to pretty much say
anything. That's what you want. You
think of I think of like my grandfather.
I can ask him a question and he'll
Yep. You know what I mean? Like he's in
no rush whatsoever. But what his yes is
his yes and his no is his no. I never
have to question that. So I I would
definitely venture to say that if you
can master the pause, you can master
communication.
>> I feel like human nature just says that
is a wise person.
>> Somebody that pauses and speaks slower.
It just it's more thought number one, it
is more thoughtful.
>> Yeah.
>> But it also [clears throat] represents
even if it's not more thoughtful, it
represents that way.
>> Yeah. Here's another thought for
financial advisors specifically and I
know this as an attorney. When I get a
question from a client, there's this
legal question, let's say they're right
in front of me, this urge for me to feel
like I need the right answer right away
and it needs to sound beautiful. And
that's just not real life. Because most
of the time, sometimes
you're just making it up, right? I I
know legal principles and I can guess
and I know the law, but every set of
facts is so different. So, how can I be
in a a place where
>> [clears throat]
>> I'm going to know with a thousand%
certainty of something. I generally
don't. It's I mean that's why they're
that's why you're going to trial in the
first place. That's why juries that's
why you have appeals court. That's it's
it's all over the place. But if you have
somebody that's
right in front of you and they ask you a
question, what I always try to do is
say, "Let me think."
I just I I choose to let them see me
thinking about it
rather than try to have that rapid fire
response because what it's telling them
is that what I'm about to say is
actually thought about because they're
not they're not always paying me for the
action. They're paying me for the
thinking. And so it's the same thing in
the the financial world. They're they're
paying for your mind.
And so when I can ask me a question
rather than have that rapid fire, oh
yeah, yeah, yeah, we're going to do X,
Y, and Z, and this is what the plan is
and blah blah blah. If I can just stop
and go, that's a great question. Let me
think about it. It works with your
spouse, too. She asks you something, he
asks you something, and you go,
>> I want to think before I respond to
that.
>> All right. Or somebody
>> would have avoided a lot of conflict
over the years if I would have done
that. Yeah, I'm telling you it's
[clears throat] well it's it's come from
a lot of pain, [laughter]
but it or if somebody says something
that's kind of rude to you or ugly to
you, rather than snapping back, say,
"Yeah, I'm going to need some time with
that before I respond." I mean, that's
>> You almost just black belt ninjas.
>> You just do. You just uh You really do.
You You um you jujitsued them. You
really do. [laughter]
They're like, "Man, I I don't even know
where to go with this right now."
>> Yeah. Well, it ends up that they they
put themselves in a headlock,
>> you know, that's and that's that's what
you want. Uh to be able to uh
communicate
in a way that
>> look, I'm going to make you feel bad
about yourself and I don't have to say
anything.
>> Like that's that's a pretty powerful way
to communicate.
>> How do we communicate with someone who
doesn't want to communicate with us?
Because often that could be our partner,
our parent or someone that we love
deeply.
>> Yeah.
>> And we want to talk to them about
something meaningful, but they don't
really even want to engage. Is it
possible?
>> It's possible.
>> I get a lot of questions of people who
are estranged from usually adult
children. there's, you know, their
30year-old son doesn't want to talk to
his mom or a a daughter who doesn't want
to talk to her dad and they haven't
spoken in three years. And every time I
have that kind of conversation, it it
breaks my heart because you can tell and
look at this parent, they want to have a
conversation with their child. And you
know, deep down, so does that that
child. They need that relationship. How
do you how do you crack that code? What
[snorts] I have found most successful
and what I teach them is I begin with
saying I know I'm not and I'm open. And
it sounds like this. I know there's
distance between us. I know things
aren't how we both want them to be. I
know I've messed up. Whatever that is. I
you you're saying what is a given two is
I'm not I'm not asking to change your
mind. I'm not asking for an apology. I'm
not asking for whatever it is. What they
think that's what you're after. And
three is I'm open. I'm open to a
conversation. I'm open and I'm open I'm
open to listening. I'm open in I'm open
to understanding. Whenever you can just
crack the door open of saying the
conversation is here. And sometimes
that's not enough. They're not going to
do it. And in that case, what I like to
say is then you have to live out the
conversation and understand that if you
can't be a bridge, be a lighthouse. You
know, if I if they don't want to come
across to me and they've burned the
bridge, well, then they're at least
going to know where I am and they're
going to know what I stand for and
they're going to see the light that I
I'm going to try to bring even if they
don't want to talk.
>> I know I'm not I'm open.
>> Yeah.
>> I really like that. Yeah.
>> I I really really like that. Especially
the I'm not.
>> Right. Exactly. I feel like that's such
an important one because I feel like
half the time it's like
I [sighs] I know we're not where we want
to be, but I'd love it if you
>> you got it. Yeah, exactly. They're
waiting for the, you know, I know
there's this, but you just, you know,
and they're expecting who's going to
apologize first.
>> Yeah.
>> I think that that for relationships and
family, you know, the hard stuff, it
becomes this petty fight over, well, I'm
not doing anything till they apologize.
and well, okay, you do it at your own
peril. Then say goodbye to it. Say
goodbye to it because they both dug in
their heels and nobody's going to change
unless somebody decides to do something
different.
>> And when you can just change the
narrative by 1% and say, I'm going to go
off on a ledge and do something
different. I've seen more relationships
come back together. I've seen more
people come back and say, "Thank you so
much. I we're actually going to meet up
for coffee. She's coming to Christmas
this year. Oh my gosh, like that. What
What is life not about if not that?
>> I really hope everyone who's listening
or watching, you know, tries that out.
>> You do that so well. You know, I've seen
that with you'll say, "When's the last
time you talked to somebody?
>> Grab your phone. Call them. Call them
now."
>> Yeah.
>> Call them now. Why? Why wait? Was would
you have to wait to be ready? Call them
now. And when you choose to do something
different, you choose to be the first,
they say, "Oh, you know, I'm tired of
being the bigger person." Well, that's
>> that's life. Yeah. Then you then you do
it with the understanding that things
are not going to be different unless
something is different.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I always I always come back
to what is the outcome that I want.
>> Yeah.
>> Like if the outcome I want is for this
person and know how I feel, then I might
have to be the bigger person. I might
have to be first.
>> I might have to be apologetic. I might
have to be more compassionate. Mhm.
>> But if that serves my ultimate goal,
which is this person knows how I feel,
then I should be willing to become
anything.
>> That's right.
>> But if my goal is to set a boundary and
not let someone cross it,
>> right?
>> Then I may actually even have to become
more guarded. I may have to become more
reserved. I may have to I have to become
all these other things. And then you
say, "Oh, but I don't want to be
reserved." But it's like, but that
serves your goal.
>> Absolutely.
>> And and so you've got to know what your
objective is or what your what your goal
is of any conversation. And I know you
talk about how winning is never the goal
of any argument,
>> even though that's what we all think.
>> Yeah. Especially being a an attorney,
people are like, "I know what you're
supposed to do." And it's that's just
not the that's not the truth. It's not
like it is on TV. You You will lose
cases. In fact, if you haven't tried if
you haven't lost a case, you haven't
tried enough cases is what they say in
the in the attorney world. Because I
can't I can't choose the law that
applies. I can't choose my client's
facts. You have to play the cards that
that you're dealt. But how I advocate it
is different. What I teach is arguments
are not something to win. They're
something to unravel. You find knots in
conversations. In law, there's this
thing called the jury instructions.
Meaning at the very end of the trial,
let's say you you've had two weeks worth
of evidence. You had openings, all all
your your motions, and you're finally at
the end and the juryy's about to go back
and make a decision on something. They
have a document called the jury
instructions and it's written out who's
responsible this person this person they
do this yes or no they add percentages
they might add money whatever it is it
is this document that controls the
ultimate outcome of the entire case and
good attorneys start with the jury
instructions when they first get a new
file bad attorneys wait till the very
end way in relationships like you
mentioned if I know where the goal is
everything else becomes fluff everything
else becomes irrelevant. So what if they
said that thing two years ago that you
could bring up? So what if they, you
know, said it a way that they rolled
their eyes? Can can you have a little
bit more emotional resilience to
understand what's happening in that
moment to not be clouded by the forest,
you know, the trees through the forest
to be able to see what's happening in
real life. So start with your end. have
a goal for the conversation
and and make sure if I if I could say
with you, let's say you and I are off
and I say, "Jay, I I know we're about to
have a difficult conversation and I want
you to know I'm going to be in it here
with you." I mean, how encouraged do you
feel of knowing I'm not trying to
abandon you in it. I'm not trying to
push something at you. And when you are
able to slow it down and see arguments
as not something to win but something to
unravel, you find so much more in the
connection.
>> How can you maintain control of yourself
in the conversation when the other
person begins to act a little
irrational?
>> The number one thing you can do to make
sure that you say things with control,
which is step one of what I teach in my
book, The Next Conversation, is you say
it with control. And that means you have
to put your breath as the first word
that you say. So when you put breath
before you even say anything else, you
you think of it as an actual word that
you're putting in first. So you're
starting with your breath. It keeps the
emotions from getting flooded. No matter
how unreasonable this other person is
being, how emotional and and responsive
they are being, reactionary is the
better word. Using your breath keeps you
more in control. Now, if you and I are
in a argument and all of a sudden I
start raising my voice and I start
yelling at you and are you kidding me?
Versus
taking a breath and saying, "Okay,
keep talking. Tell me more." And which
one sounds more in control? Which one
says, "I'm grasping for a control." The
other one says, "I am in control."
Whenever you can put breath as the first
word that you say, you naturally are in
control because you have that moment
before the argument really even begins.
Before you go into your ignition mode in
this and start getting into the hard
fire or flight, you are making sure that
you are keeping your analytical side
engaged. So really the the tip that
anybody can do is making breath be the
first word that you say. It's going to
make it a whole lot better. Like if you
were to ask me, uh, hey Jefferson, how
how was your day? And immediately I
said, it was good. It was good. It was
fine. It was a good day. Versus you just
asked me, hey, how was your day? And I
took a breath and
it was good. It was a good day. Like,
which one sounds like you actually
thought about the question? Which one
makes you feel like you acknowledged
what you said and you found it valuable?
Anytime you can use your breath and slow
down your words, slow down the response,
you always look more in control.
>> Part of being in control of the
conversation also stems from having a
level of confidence in yourself to be
able to talk about what it is that
you're talking about. How can people get
better at appearing and becoming
confident during conversations? So, rule
two of my book is say it with
confidence. And the way that I like to
implement this into my clients and to
people that follow my content is you
have to find an assertive voice. People
feel like confidence is something they
need to have before they have the
conversation. Like, I'm working up the
confidence to say this. It's wrong. It's
it's it's the opposite. Confidence is
the outcome. Confidence is what you get
after you do the assertive thing. So I
teach confidence is as assertive does.
So when you can use your assertive voice
and that is what is going to give you
the pieces of confidence that will
continue to just be in a loop. The more
assertive things you say, the more
confident you feel. The more confident
you feel, the easier it is to be
assertive. And it is a sense that is
within you of I know where I am. So once
you feel more in control, you
automatically sound and feel more
confident. A quick little trick that I
use aside from one of the ways we could
talk about assertive voice is just using
the word confident. Just using the word
confident naturally makes you appear and
sound and feel more confident. Like if
I'm interviewing for you and you ask me
a question, I could say if I if I said I
believe I could really bring some value
to this team versus I'm confident I can
bring some value to this team. All of a
sudden the other person you're going to
get your notepad and go, man, this
person sounds confident. And just using
that word attributes that quality to
you, not only to the other person, but
also to yourself, which is incredibly
important. I want to talk about how to
get better at speaking in an assertive
way. You know, you and I touched on this
and covered this in our first
conversation and I catch myself
sometimes like fluffing up like an email
like, "Hey, hope all is well." You know,
just instead of just getting to the
point, I think you and I talked about
this because I think sometimes I my
guess my conscious is like, "Oh, are
they going to think that I'm not caring
or empathetic?" You know, and many
people do this. So talk a bit about like
why that doesn't matter as much and and
and how to become more assertive.
>> It does matter. It's just it's not about
using more words. It's about using the
right words. Where people get bogged
down is they feel like if they say more
things they will be more believable, be
more liked. It it it will reap
additional even more benefits. But it's
actually just the opposite. If you were
to say to me, "Invite me somewhere." And
all of a sudden, I start a very long
text like, "Hey, Doug, thank you so much
for inviting me." Like, I just, you
know, I I've just been so busy lately
and, you know, I need to go water my cat
and feed my house and and do all these
uh things and I need to, you know, and
I've just been so overwhelmed. The more
you say, the less believable you sound,
the more fluff that you add into it.
It's this concept of the more words it
takes to tell the truth, the more it
sounds like a lie. So when you are
responding in emails, let's for let's
just put it in written correspondence.
You're typing, you're texting, whatever.
There's the tendency to give more, but
nobody wants to read a long paragraph.
As soon as you get that paragraph text,
you go, "Oh gosh." And you and you miss
a lot of the key points. Same thing with
a long email. There's nothing worse than
a long email. All you did was you gave
me a chore. That's what you gave me. You
didn't give me an email. You gave me You
gave me a chore for me to dissect
exactly what you're trying to say. The
problem we run into is we just use a lot
of fluff. Use a lot of adverbs. Yeah. I
have a I have a friend who he almost
always starts a sentence with so
basically or so essentially. That's just
fluff that that don't mean anything.
Using words like just, so, essent
essentially, literally, basically,
obviously, clearly, all these things
that mean nothing. You don't you don't
need them. You just remove them from
your sentences. There's a difference in
how it sounds. If I were to email you,
hey, just want to check in versus I
wanted to check in. Just removing that
word just makes it less hesitant, less
uh like you're not sure of yourself and
you don't want to intrude. It's leaning
into your conversation, leading into
your word. So, the best rule is to
always say less. If people have
questions, they will ask you. You want
to make sure that you are being a well
of information, not a waterfall of it.
>> And when it comes to like maybe like
texting with your significant other or
somebody that you're dating, I would
imagine you have to be careful with how
direct you are because if somebody's
like, "How's your day?" You're like,
"It's great." And you don't say anything
else. Your perception might be like,
"Yeah, I'm just being honest." And
that's what it is. How does it differ
when you're like communicating with
somebody that you love?
>> Yeah. Well, I mean, it could be not just
people you love, but really anyone. I'm
not saying be short. There's a
difference between being short and
saying less. Being short is the it's
great, good, okay, cool. Like typical
dad texts. That's what this is how my
dad texts. Like I could text him all
some cool things that are happening and
I'll just get back cool. You know what I
mean? Like there are ways that Yeah. If
I were to respond to my wife and just go
K, like I might as well just signed a
death warrant. Like it's just never it's
not going to do any good. So there is a
difference when I say being short versus
being concise. And if you want to say
it's been an awesome day, thank you.
Versus the well, it's a little bit
different because in personal
relationships, we want to know more. I'd
say there's a difference most of the
time between men and women of who want
to know all the things and how you're
feeling about all the things versus us
guys, bros, if you're going to text me,
our text threads going to be pretty
short and pretty boring. But that
doesn't mean that we're not tight and
we're not friends and we're not still
great on the same page. It just is very
different. I find most of our our
defaults. But when it comes to personal
communication, it is best policy to be
direct and be open and be honest rather
than beginning with all of the fluff. I
[snorts] don't mean like don't don't
tell them how you're feeling. You don't
need to that that's wonderful. That's
necessary. Uh my biggest things
particularly in the work place is you
want to be very careful of
overexplaining and oversharing. That's
when you can get into trouble. And so
when it comes to remaining assertive and
having respect for yourself and and and
gaining respect from other people, I
think what can happen is you send that
assertive email or text to a boss, a
colleague, etc., and their response
isn't what you thought it would be. And
sometimes people end up maybe wanting to
give a little bit more so they can, you
know, appease that person. How can
people maintain assertiveness throughout
correspondence
to be able to maintain a level of uh
respect?
>> Yeah, let's put it in a context. Give me
let's do a some type of scenario. Are
you because it changes, you know,
between if it's a superior, somebody
who's a supervisor above you or somebody
who's below you. So, what kind of
scenario do you want to take?
>> I would say the common thing, let's just
say amongst friends or something.
>> Yeah. And let's what are we talking
about? I want to make sure like cuz if
you want to be assertive in that
conversation among friends that's a
little bit more it's a little bit more
difficult like there are people who are
work friends like it just people that
you know but you necessarily wouldn't
want to you know go hang out with them
after work but you're you're cool and
your buddies during the office hours and
there are other people that are
genuinely you know your people your
tribe your village
>> I would say the people that are your
tribe your village like you're trying to
communicate maybe something that bothers
you about that or you're trying to bring
up something and you're assertive about
it and they kind of come back and
they're they get maybe defensive or say
you're wrong and then you're still
trying to maintain your your boundary
without caving essentially.
>> Yeah. So a lot of the times what you can
do is you give them the permission to
disagree.
You're giving them the permission to
have another opinion. So if you respond
with it's okay to disagree or you can
disagree with me like that's that's what
they need.
They're not expecting that first of all.
But when you can use that to your
advantage is say yeah it's it's cool.
You can have a different opinion. That's
I I'm letting you how know how I feel.
I'm not trying to control how you feel.
I'm just telling you what is going to be
right for me. So like my dad would say
this whenever I would bring let's say
there's something that was happening
that I didn't like and he made a
decision on something that I couldn't I
couldn't go somewhere. I couldn't you
know whatever my curfew was and I was
voicing my disapproval. He would always
say well you don't have to like it. You
just need to understand it. Like that
was that was the key. And of course, as
a kid, I hated that. But now I see the
wisdom in it because he was allowing me
the space to connect with him and
disagree to say, "Oh, you don't have to
like it. Hey, you don't have to like it,
but you just need to understand it." And
I think that's where we get lost
sometimes is this idea of connecting
with the other person. Connection.
It's a it's a circuit. It's like a
battery. You have to have the positive
and the negative. If I can connect with
you and still be upset with you, I can
still disagree with you. Like connection
doesn't mean that I approve or I agree
and that we're a Hallmark movie. It's
connection is just as important in the
negative and the hard and in the
difficult.
>> You don't have one thing I've noticed
about you. You're not one word reliant.
So I want to ask you about that. Just a
couple more hacks you guys before we
wrap up. But I uh a lot of people will
overuse you. just did a piece of content
I loved on people who say like like like
like it's like it's like it's like it's
like in my case I have this reliance on
uh literally I overuse the word
literally right I've just noticed it
listening to my stage speaking listening
to podcast I literally use literally too
much so let's just take somebody even
who uses the word like I mean and by the
way everyone listening right now
you probably have a phrase or word that
you use way more than than you realize,
right? They do. And so I'm wondering
about any strategy or tact we could even
stay on like if you choose, but should
people be aware they do that to some
extent as well. And um I want to say
literally, so I'll just let you answer.
>> Well, yeah. Yeah. So, yeah, they're all
uh adverbs. They're all adverbs, words
in an L Y. um or they they try and do
things in sentences that add a lot of
fluff. So like is one of them. So just
literally essentially I have a best
friend who will always start a sentence
with. So basically uh like you don't
those are both adverbs. It's very easy
to do because we use that in social
casual conversation. If you want to
eliminate using the word like all the
time, swap it for the word because. It
forces you to move the conversation
forward. So instead of saying something
to the effect of I didn't like when you
said that, like it it really made me
feel um less versus I didn't like when
you said that because it made me feel
less. It's adding the cause and effect
in there like it's just a fluff filler
word literally is as you know also a big
ad word. And what they do is they just
water down your sentences. They don't
mean anything. I my my one that I have
is just, which is not great either. So
you can tell the difference of somebody
going, "Hey, just want to check in
versus I wanted to check in." You remove
the word just, it doesn't sound nearly
as hesitant. The biggest thing with
adverbs is you find a way not to to use
them. Like literally, there's not a
there's not a flip or a word I would say
you need to replace it with this. It's
just not using the word. That's a lot
easier easier said than done of trying
to catch yourself. And there's nothing
wrong with them in casual conversation.
It's when you're wanting to
be assertive when you're having to have
a really important conversation that
literally kind of just clogs up the
sentence because they don't know what to
do with it. They hear it. Like there's a
difference between if I were to say so
like I mean literally if I mean and
maybe you don't think this way but so I
was just thinking like but essentially
and you're like what are they saying
versus just scrapping all of that and
getting right to the getting right to
the point. What if you were all just a
little bit better at all of this? I just
want you to think about it. Just if you
had a tool chest full of these things
that you're just a little bit better at
all of these things. You're a little bit
more persuasive. Your content on social
media is a little bit better. you're a
little bit better in front of a crowd.
Your interpersonal relationships flow
just a little bit better. Think about
the implications of this in your life.
And is there much are there many things
you could do that could increase the
quality of your productivity and your
happiness more than what we're
describing right now or instantly?
Because I don't believe that there is
literally no pun intended. So last
question regarding silence. So, I've
watched you today and you listen
quietly.
You don't do a lot of what I call
emotional nudges. Uh-huh. Yes. Right.
You don't speed me up. You listen to the
end of a sentence. I just want to give
you a whole package on the topic of
silence. My
opinion is that the best communicators I
know utilize silence better than other
people. Meaning the following. I'm going
to throw the whole package at you. My
best standup friends when they watched
me speak, the advice they would give me,
the ones that have been on the show is,
Ed, a little bit more silence, make the
point, and be quiet, let the audience
clap, let them have the emotion before
you move on to the next one. Don't talk
over the punchline is one of the rules
in comedy. Uh, listening quietly. Um,
processing information after somebody
speaks. All of this whole package of
just silence and its actual unbelievable
ability to be communicative to people is
the part that I wanted to finish with
and maybe in my mind the most important
part of communication just stage
interpersonal persuasion presenting all
of it listening silence. What does that
mean to you when I say it? Silence is
without a doubt the most powerful tool
anybody can have in their communication
because it may be the absence of words.
It's not the absence of communication.
Silence is always communicating
something. And you even some of the best
I would say your best attorneys, your
best lawyers are ones that don't try and
step over the witness's answer. They are
listening intently. That's when I know I
have somebody on the other side I need
to worry about because they're not
writing down notes. They're not looking
for their next question. They're just
looking and listening. And when that's
happening, I'm going, "Oh, okay. Now,
now I'm in some with somebody who's who
can play." So, it is anytime you're
listening to somebody, if you begin to
kind of really engage, I I know that
goes different for different types of
people and their personality, but when
you can just sit and listen, it's
saying, "I'm 100% devoted to this
moment. I'm not wishing I was somewhere
else. I'm not trying to speed this up so
I can get out. Um, I'm not trying to
focus on me and what I'm going to say
next and my my story that I'm going to
share that's going to be hopefully
better than yours. It is just an
appreciation for letting you shine,
letting the spotlight be on you and me
having this sense of wonder to say,
"What can I learn from this moment?" And
when you begin to have every one of your
conversations with this mindset of
having something to learn and not
something to prove, better things are
going to happen in your life when you
start to slow down and realize where
you're going. If you enjoyed that clip
and want to see the rest of the
conversation, you can click right here.